حياه هؤلاء لا تهددها الحرب حسب بل
الانهيارات الصخريه المتساقطه على رؤوسهم
هذه الطفله احدى ضحايا انهيار صخري ادخلها
العنايه المركزه في غيبوبه دماغيه وثلاثه
من اخوتها ايضا في المشفى بعد ان تعدت
حالاتهم مرحله الخطر انهم ضحايا انهيار
صخريا باغتهم في المنزل ليلا في قريه الشن
بمنطقه الضباب غربي تعز
عاصفه قويه فلا الصخره على البيت
وانا خرجت يعني خوف انا اجمل الاطفال
[موسيقى]
تحت التراب لمده نصف ساعه وخرجوها
وان لهم السعاده
وبعدين تم نقل عمله هنا طبعا هم من الفعل
المهمشين وحالتهم معدمه جدا وصلوا
هكذا اذا يحاولوا هؤلاء انتشال ما تبقى
تحت الانقاض حتى وان كانت حيوانات او مواد
ايوائيه وهكذا بدت المنازل مدمره بالصخور
فثرواتهم الحيوانيه نفقت جميعها تحت
الركام وبات اكثر من عشرين شخصا في الاسره
يعيشون التشرد في منازل المجاوره عقب وقوع
الكارثه
هذه الاحداث والاصابات
ونتمنى من
المعنيه بالامر اتخاذ الاجراءات المناسبه
للحي الاولاد دون
تكرار مثل هذه
الواقعه ليست هذه المره الاولى التي
تتساقط فيها الصخور على منازل المواطنين
بل ثمت واقعه مشابهه حدثت قبل اشهر في
منطقه الحصيب وسط المدينه اثارت حاله من
الرعب وسط السكان وامام تلك الحوادث
المتكرره جراء الامطار الغزيره والعواصف
تقف الجهات الحكوميه عاجزه عن تقديم اي حل
هل سعيد العربيه تعز لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج
والقصه على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات